Can y'all keep up.
Why don't you pump the breaks.
It's our last month in the Oval
Office.
Hopefully we qualify for some
unemployments.
Ain't no place in the workforce
for a real nig.
Aghhhh
Damn it's about to be Obamas
last days as President.
What ya'll think?
Well hopefully he run through
some Instagram model
Before the
closing ceremonies.
Yeah last days in the White
House.
He better not go out tryin' to
be faithful.
Ughhhhh
Come on Y'all, how am I supposed
to make the MBA.
If Donald Trump brings America
on its Knees.
I say don't worry because
Trump probably get bounced
soon.
His Vegas casino isn't even on
the strip.
Dude is a peasant.
Well they say he gonna try to
ship us back to Africa.
Well I'ma let y'all worry
about shit you can't control.
And I'ma just keep being
League.
Well shit Jamal if you League
then I'm Lebron James.
Well shit if you Lebron
James...I'm
The white guy from Forest Gump?
Da white guy from White Men
Can't Jump?
Well you do look like Donald
Trump.
Beast!